in a paper title pushing the frontiers
of density functionals by solving the
fractional electron problem so you're
taking on
modeling and simulating the quantum
mechanical behavior of electrons
yes um
can you explain this work and can ai
model and simulate arbitrary quantum
mechanical systems in the future yeah so
this is another problem i've had my eye
on for you know a decade or more which
is um
uh sort of simulating the properties of
electrons if you can do that you can
basically describe how elements and
materials and substances work so it's
kind of like fundamental if you want to
advance material science
and uh you know we have schrodinger's
equation and then we have approximations
to that density functional theory these
things are you know are famous and um
people try and write approximations to
to these uh uh to these functionals and
and kind of come up with descriptions of
the electron clouds where they're going
to go how they're going to interact when
you put two elements together
and what we try to do is learn a
simulation
learner functional that will describe
more chemistry types of chemistry
so um until now you know you can run
expensive simulations but then you can
only simulate very small
molecules very simple molecules we would
like to simulate large materials
and so today there's no way of doing
that and we're building up towards uh
building functionals that approximate
schrodinger's equation and then allow
you to describe uh what the electrons
are doing
and all materials sort of science and
material properties are governed by the
electrons and and how they interact so
have a good summarization of the
simulation
through the functional
um
but one that is still
close to what the actual simulation
would come out with so what um
how difficult is that to ask what's
involved in that task is it running
those those complicated simulations yeah
and learning the task of mapping from
the initial conditions and the
parameters of the simulation learning
what the functional would be yeah so
it's pretty tricky and we've done it
with um you know the nice thing is we
there are we can run a lot of the
simulations the the molecular dynamic
simulations on our compute clusters and
so that generates a lot of data so in
this case the data is generated so we
like those sort of systems and that's
why we use games it's simulated
generated data uh and we can kind of
create as much of it as we want really
um and just let's leave some you know if
any computers are free in the cloud we
just run we run some of these
calculations right compute cluster
calculations are the the free compute
times used up on quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics exactly simulations
and protein simulations and other things
and so um and so you know when you're
not searching on youtube for video cat
videos we're using those computers
usefully in quantum chemistry the idea
and and uh putting them for good use and
then yeah and then all of that
computational data that's generated we
can then try and learn the functionals
from that which of course are way more
efficient once we learn the functional
then
running those simulations would be
you